♪ (PENSIVE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: It's in all of us...
that fear of being hurt...
because we're queer.
♪ (DISCO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Thank you, New York,
for being so fabulous.
SPEAKER: I remember the first
gay bar I walked into,
I thought, "Oh, my god,
I've been missing this
my entire life."
It just felt like home.
SPEAKER 2: Queer bars were one
of the few places
where we could come
and feel safe.
SPEAKER 3:
And then, all of a sudden...
-♪ (MUSIC ENDS ABRUPTLY)
-everything was taken away.
SPEAKER 4:
Dismembered human remains
were found in plastic bags
along roadways
outside New York City.
SPEAKER 5: My dad went down
to New York
on a business trip
and never came home.
-SPEAKER 6: My brother.
-My uncle.
-SPEAKER 7: My friend.
-SPEAKER 8: He just disappeared.
SPEAKER 9:
These were pick up crimes.
They were last seen
at a gay bar.
5 Oaks, the Townhouse.
Clearly, a serial murderer
going after gay men
was on the loose.
SPEAKER 3:
It was so frightening
'cause everyone was a suspect.
The queer community
was very much trying to
push law enforcement
to give a shit.
At this time,
we wouldn't put it past
-the police to kill us.
-♪ (SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 10: Hate crimes
against gays and lesbians
are up all over the country.
Makes people feel like
maybe they're not safe
and maybe a murderer
isn't gonna get caught.
SPEAKER 3: We were scared.
This guy is gonna strike again,
and could I be next?
-Peter Anderson.
-SPEAKER 11: Thomas Mulcahy.
-SPEAKER 12: Anthony Marrero.
-SPEAKER 13: Michael Sakara.
They weren't just a statistic.
They had their own story too.
This guy was
a serial killer for years.
SPEAKER 14:
Was he gonna make a mistake?
How does someone get away
with something like that?